today we're going to talk about 10
things you didn't know about bitcoin
firstly we have the mysterious creator
now in 2009 a person
or a group of people known as satoshi
nakamoto introduced bitcoin to the world
he vanished off the internet in late
2010.
he hasn't been heard from since now just
like his identity is shorter than
mystery
nobody really knows if he's even alive
or dead the only communication people
had with him
were through emails and forums his
bitcoin wallet holds around 980
000 bitcoins which makes him one of the
richest people on the planet
next up we have the satoshi now as a
sign of respect for the bitcoins creator
the smallest unit of a bitcoin
is known as a satoshi once satoshi is
valued at around
zero 0.0000 six six nine four u s
dollars which is a very very low value
now to make one bitcoin you need
approximately hundred million satoshi's
now according to the current bitcoin
values which fluctuates a lot
to make a dollar you need close to 15
800 satoshi's
losing bitcoins losing your bitcoin
address which is also known as your
private key
not only means losing your unique
identification it also means you lose
all the bitcoins in your wallet research
shows that at least 60 percent of all
bitcoin addresses
are ghosts which means a huge chunk of
the population that's using the bitcoin
network
have lost their addresses now these are
the people who have lost their addresses
and have no way to access their wallet
liberland
now in april 2015 a micro nation between
croatia
and serbia known as liberland was born
now this was founded by virgilka
a politician publicist activist and the
president of liberland
now the official currency of liberland
is bitcoin now the government took this
move
believing that bitcoin and its
underlying concepts of blockchain
provides a secure and transparent method
for recording electronic
financial and physical assets processing
power the process of mining bitcoins
is a expensive process now you pay a
high tour to do this
like your money your time and
electricity now
mining bitcoins require servers that are
used for that specific purpose alone now
the faster you process the data the
faster the block can be added to the
blockchain
and the faster you're rewarded with
bitcoins power consumption
now just imagine how much electricity
ireland consumes in a year
approximately 5000 kilowatt hour now how
much do you think
all the bitcoin mining farms together
consume 60 terawatt r
which is approximately 6 into 10 raised
to 10 kilowatt hours which is a large
amount of power
now the entire country of ireland which
is the second most populated city in
europe
and has 84 421 kilometer square of area
consumes lesser electricity than all
these farms combined
bitcoin ban now although several
countries around the world
like canada and america have
wholeheartedly accepted bitcoin there
are some that haven't
countries like bolivia iceland
bangladesh and ecuador have completely
banned the usage of bitcoins
there are also countries like india
thailand and iran who ask their
residents to be careful while using
cryptocurrencies they haven't completely
banned it however they do not
accept it as a legal tender law limited
number
there's a limit to how many bitcoins can
exist in the market
this number is capped at 21 million
bitcoins
as of this moment 17 million bitcoins
are already in circulation
to give you an idea that's almost 80
percent of the 21 million
already done but don't worry until 21.40
we'll still have bitcoins to mine
this is because of how miners are
rewarded now miners are rewarded with
12.5 bitcoins for each block
added to the blockchain and every four
years the reward reduces by half
the next halving is supposed to occur in
2020 where the reward reduces to 6.25
bitcoins
the power of b the terms bitcoin with an
uppercase b
and bitcoin with the lowercase b mean
two different things
the only thing that differentiates the
two into two completely different things
is the letter b
the lowercase b in bitcoin refers to the
cryptocurrency that is used to perform
the transactions
the uppercase b in bitcoin refers to the
ledger that stores information regarding
these transactions
faster than supercomputers the world's
fastest supercomputer the summit works
at 122.3 petaflops
which is nothing but a quadrillion
floating point operations per second now
if you take the bitcoin network
completely into consideration
the processing power is about 80 million
704
290 petaflops but the only thing here is
that a supercomputer can do several
different things but the only thing the
bitcoin network does
is add blocks to the blockchain and with
that we've reached the end of the video
i hope you guys enjoyed it and i've
learned something new about bitcoin if
you feel like we've missed out on
something interesting that you've come
across
let us know in the comments below thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here